[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben ich habe euch auch
instagram schon ein wenig verrückt
gemacht denn ich habe so sehr von dem
kaffee kuchen meiner schwiegermutter
geschwärmt dass ich ihn letztendlich für
euch abgefilmt habe das besondere ist
einfach dass man zwischen den zwei
leckeren mürbeteig böden die einfach
nach kekse schmecken diesen leckeren
kaffee muss koren hat und der beinhaltet
kein zusätzliches mail für den mürbeteig
benötigen wir 600 gramm kalte butter
oder margarine außerdem 800 gramm mehl
acht es so viel milch und 120 gramm
zucker ich hab hier vanillezucker
genommen ihr könnt aber auch den
normalen nehmen
[Musik]
jetzt müssen alle zutaten zügig
miteinander verkettet werden und ich
arbeite da am liebsten auf der
arbeitsfläche
zu meinem mail gebe ich dann noch den
zucker verrühren das ganz kurz gruppen
miteinander und dann gebe ich die milch
in eine mulde
[Musik]
anschließend geben wir die kalte butter
mit hinzu und ich habe sie hier schon in
stückchen geschnitten so lässt sie sich
schön und einfach verarbeiten
auch wenn ihr das gefühl habt der teig
lässt sich ja nie verbinden das wird
schon also knetet fleißig weiter und
nach ein bis zwei minuten erhaltet ihr
dann so einen schönen kompakten teig den
mürbeteig teile ich jetzt in zwei gleich
große hälften und packe sie separat in
frischhaltefolie 1
wenn sie jetzt auch noch flach drückt
dann kühlen sie schneller durch und die
habt weniger wartezeit
[Musik]
so gebe ich das ganze jetzt für
mindestens eine stunde in den
kühlschrank
[Musik]
für die leckere café nuss füllung von
der ich so geschwärmt habe benötigen wir
acht eiweiß eine prise salz 8 1 gelb
außerdem 500 gramm zucker 500 gramm
gemahlene nüsse ich habe hier haselnüsse
verwendet außerdem vier esslöffel batak
und zwei bis drei esslöffel instant
kaffee
[Musik]
zuerst wird das eiweiß mit einer guten
prise salz und der hälfte des zuckers in
etlichen maschine komplett steif
geschlagen
die prise salz dient dazu dass die
eiweiß struktur schneller zerstört wird
und somit die baiser masse schneller
steif wird
[Musik]
sobald das eiweiß dann komplett steif
geschlagen wurde und dir so eine
schaumstoff artige masse habt dann könnt
ihr das ganze zur seite legen und in
einer separaten schüssel das eigelb
aufschlagen
[Musik]
zum ein gelb geben wir dann noch den
restlichen zucker und schlagen das mit
dem schneebesen circa drei bis vier
minuten lang bis wir eine weiß cremige
masse erhalten
[Musik]
die eib zuckermasse gewinnt dann an
dreifachen volumen und ihr habt so eine
schöne cremige masse und dann könnt ihr
die bg masse unterheben
[Musik]
und hier empfiehlt es sich nicht alles
auf einmal unter zu heben damit ihr da
auch schön das gefühl dafür habt und
nicht die ganze luft raus schlägt und
benutzt auch am besten einen teig
schaber und kein schneebesen
[Musik]
wald es dann schön unter gehoben wurde
sieben wir den bug oder rein damit auch
keine klümpchen entstehen
[Musik]
auch hier wieder mit dem teig schaber
vorsichtig unterheben
[Musik]
der stelle könnt ihr noch den
instant-kaffee hinzufügen das rezept ist
übrigens sehr variabel wenn ihr mehr
kaffee möge dann gibt gerne mehr hinzu
wenn ihr es ganz sein lassen wollt dann
könnt ihr das auch komplett weglassen
zu guter letzt themen wir noch
vorsichtig die gemahlenen haselnüssen
unter
falls ihr den schritt dann auch erledigt
habt ist die leckere kaffee kuchen
füllung soweit fertig und wir können
weitermachen mit dem mürbeteig
ein mürbeteig habe ich mir noch im
kühlschrank gelassen den anderen packe
ich geradeaus und knete ihn 30 sekunden
lang zu einem glatten teig
[Musik]
hier braucht ihr auch nicht zu lange
kneten denn wir wollen ja nicht dass der
markt wieder weich wird der soll einfach
nur ganz kurz durchgeknetet werden und
anschließend können wir ihnen zwischen
zwei backpapier ausrollen
[Musik]
das rezept ist für ein blech gedacht das
wird also einen blechkuchen und deswegen
wollte ich mir den mürbeteig auch so
quadratisch und so groß wie möglich aus
[Musik]
dann gebe ich das ganze zusammen mit dem
backpapier auf ein backblech und
versuchen noch die ecken zu füllen und
zu begradigen
[Musik]
hier habt ihr nun zwei möglichkeiten
entweder ihr schied den mürbeteig bis
zum rand eures backblech oder ägypter so
einen eckigen back raum drum
[Musik]
sobald ihr dann zufrieden seid gebt ihr
die kaffee nuss füllung drauf
[Musik]
die füllung dann noch überall schön
verteilen und glatt streichen und dann
gehen wir schon den zweiten tag boden
drauf
[Musik]
hier fand ich es einfacher den mürbeteig
in mehrere teile zum dateien denn das
ganze stück würde mir dann doch kaputt
gehen und so kann ich dann immer schritt
für schritt arbeiten
[Musik]
die märkte böten dürfen auch ruhig
überlappen dass es gar kein problem im
anschnitt sieht man das sowieso nicht
mehr
[Musik]
nun wird der kuchen bei 170 grad ober
und unterhitze für 45 bis 50 minuten
gebacken und so sieht dann das
endergebnis aus
ich habe dann noch ein wenig puderzucker
darüber gestreut das sieht optisch immer
sehr schön aus aber das ist natürlich
wieder vollkommen euch überlassen und
falls jetzt auch auf den geschmack
gekommen seid und den leckeren kaffee
kuchen nach machen möchtet dann schaut
man in die infobox da habe ich euch alle
zutaten aufgeschrieben
[Musik]
ich wünsche euch viel spaß beim
nachbacken und freue mich wenn ihr das
nächste mal wieder einschaltet tschüss
[Musik]